okay let's get started so in this talk
i'll tell you about our recent results
on some linear time and space algorithms
for correlation plus three this is a
joint work with my divider separa at
rutgers
so to begin with let me motivate this
problem and define what is correlation
clustering
so correlation clustering has its
applications in real world so for
example if we are giving n documents and
each document is about some topic okay
and of each pair of documents are either
similar or dissimilar so for example for
these three documents the first about
u.s election the second one is value
after champions league which is a
famous soccer tournament and the third
one is about climate change summit
okay so our goal is to find a clustering
that puts similar documents together and
designers apart for example among these
three documents the first and third are
more or less similar they are about
politics and the second was sports so
we're going to put the first sensor
together and the second one in another
cluster
so the problem becomes very interesting
when a document
is similar to multiple documents that
are mutually dissimilar
for example they are giving the first
document barcelona and catalan
independence
so barcelona is a soccer club that
competes in uf a chinese medic but it's
also involved in some political
movements
so it's similar to both the first and
second documents
however the first and second document
themselves are
dissimilar okay
so now let me be a bit more formal to
give you the formal definition for
correlation clustering so suppose we are
giving a liberal graph g equals v and e
as convention v is the set of vertices
and e the set of edges
okay so in fact
in collision clustering we deal with
liquid graph which is called the
complete graph
so
for each vertex pair there's the edge
and each edge is labeled as either
negative one or positive one
for example if i give this graph so it's
a five vertices and the its complete
graph and the edge reminds me to the
positive edge and edge of the values
through the negative edge and so on so
forth
okay
so in correlation classroom one of the
most uh well-studied goals is this
disagreement cost so what does it mean
so for the graph i've shown you so if we
implant the cluster as shown in the
picture then there are two types of
cause i want to count
the first one is a pair of vertices that
share positive edge but they are cross
in different clusters for example this
v2 and before you can think of them as a
pair of similar documents but they are
put into different clusters
okay and the second type is the negative
agency inside the seam transfers so for
example in this we threw in beforehand
it's negative
foreign for it
okay
so we are going to go over all the pairs
of the aforementioned kind that is the
shared positive edge but they are in
different clusters or they share
negative edge but in that they are in
the same posture okay and we are going
to count all of them towards the total
disagreement cost
and note that different from k-means or
center clustering so here we don't have
a predefined number of classrooms so we
can pick whatever many number of
clusters we want to minimize the cost
to give you some further example
so in this example uh
when we have revenue to be through
before and if we put viva and between a
classroom and we still refer another
cluster then we have a cost of zero
because we only have positive edges
inside clusters and next edges cross
clusters
okay
however if you some do some goofy things
instead we put v by v series four in a
cluster and we two in a single ten then
the cost is three because we're going to
pay for the positive edge of remember
two and negative edges v values three
and leaving before
okay
so let me
tell you something about the state of
affairs of course your clustering and
what are our main contributions
and there are some classical results for
correlation clustering so we know that
the exact solution for this problem
isn't hard
the best polynomial time algorithm
achieves the 2.06 approximation by
chablis at all so this algorithm is
based on some linear programming
techniques
and
for combinatorial algorithms there is
this simple pivot algorithm that
achieves a three approximation by island
at all okay
and here we talk about c approximation
i'm talking about to give a clustering
that achieves the cost of at most c opt
and here opt is the uh cost of the
optimal correction clustering
okay so
the
polynomial time algorithms is not the
end of the story so in more than the
application there's this challenge of
big data that is for some data like even
reading or storing the entire input is
prohibitively expensive
okay
so one remedy to
uh solve things that's polynomial time
algorithm that's not able to implement
it is sublinear
these algorithms works with resources
that are substantially smaller than even
the input themselves
so for example if i give you a graph
i only read part of the vertices and
edges
like that i mark as red and for the for
other vertices and the edges i either
don't read them or i don't start
okay
so
now there's a quest for some linear
algorithm for correlation clustering
especially for more than the massive
data applications
so
when talk about sublinear algorithms
there are two regimes so i'll introduce
them in order the first one is some
linear time algorithms so when talking
about some linear time we need some
model
so the standard model uh for some linear
time algorithm is this lg list model so
in constant time we can query edge and
six of our tags in constant time we can
query
one of his neighbors or we can acquire
his degree
okay
and under this model the known results
for the linear time algorithm is this
local correlation clustering uh
algorithm
by bunching at all
so they show that
within order of a lower absolute square
time they can achieve three up plus
epsilon square approximation so note
that this is different from the c
approximation i talked about because
there is an extra
additive error term of absolute square
unfortunately this absolute square
additive error seems inherent in their
paper they show that if you are only
allowed to mix more of n squared queries
to the edges that there is no c opt plus
absolute square approximation for small
constant c n on absolute okay
and in fact in our paper we showed that
if we are focusing on purely
multiplicative approximation on me
there's no
financial approximation if you're only
allowed small of n square queries to
suggest
okay even like c is exponential to n or
something
so i won't focus on the proof of these
negative results but i want to give you
some insights that to break this
quadratic barrier for more
multiplicative approximation then you
really need some new model
and in our results we use this agility
for the positive subgraph instead
so what does it mean for the list for
the positive subgraph so we take a
little bit okay now we are allowed to
query a positive in constant time and
fix the vertex v we are allowed to query
one of the neighbors one of its positive
neighbors on this positive degree in
constant time
so
to give you some more illustration i
give you the argentine list for original
graph and i color coded the positive
neighbors as the gray and negative
numbers of red
now i'm going to throw away all the
negative neighbors and only focus on
positive ones
and now for fixed vertex we can query a
positive neighbor in constant time and
then we can create a positive degree in
constant time
okay good
so our first result is shows that giving
this access to the positive sub of
gravity plus
there is there exists a linear time
algorithm that with high probability
finds a constant approximation for
correlation clustering with order of log
squared
okay compared to the omega n square
lower bound this is uh
almost quadratic improvement
so now let's change the context a little
bit and talk about sublinear space
algorithms
so we started these algorithms under the
framework of insertionally graph 3d
model so under this model we are giving
the vertices in the beginning but the
address arrives one at another industry
so for example if you
give these five vertices and when t
equals zero zero only vertices when he t
equals one this positive edge before v5
comes and t equals two the negative edge
of even v4 comes and so on so forth
okay
so an ideal algorithm
streaming algorithm works within only a
single pass
and it does not necessarily store all
the edges so indeed actually the
algorithm
are interestingly is memory smaller and
square because otherwise it can store
everything and run the best offline
algorithm
and the dreamland scenario is the memory
of order of employee login which is
called semester memory so why this is
good because actually in many
applications this is the
necessary memory to even output the
answer themselves okay for example in
college clustering we need polylog and
b's to include the cluster for each
vertex and there are enough
okay
good
so
under this semi streaming memory
constraint by the way it can also be
shorthanded and noted as authored off
and which has used these notations
throughout the talk so there are some
known results with this memory so in
this icml 15th paper and at all should
that there's a three approximation with
other flock login passes
and in the very recent paper by cohen
that at all in last year's xml he shows
that there there is a constant
approximation with six passes but before
our work there's no known results with a
single pass
so our result basically
set us this problem we gives a sublinear
space single path streaming algorithm
that with high probability finds a
constant approximation for correlation
clustering and use a memory of order of
n logarithms okay this is almost optimal
so in the rest of talk i'll give you uh
some intuition how our algorithm works
uh but before that let's do a review a
little bit and see the main challenge
for designing correlation clustering
algorithm in a sublinear regime
so earlier sublinear algorithms
for correlation clustering mostly
simulates the p1 algorithm so the pivot
technology is
extremely elegant and easy to implement
and it essentially computes a random
order maximal independent set on the
positive subgraph
okay
however to compute the maximal
independent set there are some barriers
so we know that under the digitalist
model there's omega n square time lower
bound and similarly under a single path
over the stream there's omega n square
space lower
okay
so
in the recent paper by cohen that at all
they actually achieved constant
approximation in six passes with a new
idea
so without diving into the detail of
their algorithm so
the high level idea of their algorithm
is to cluster different vertices based
on the density of their edge
connectivity
okay
so in particular for a gra for graph as
shown in the picture let's see there's a
five click here i almost five click here
and two send standalone versions
and you will put the
almost clicks in the clusters
and the standalone version says into
singletons
okay so while this is good
let's just give some intuition so if we
focus on these positive errors that is
going to be paid by uh this kind of
clustering
and so if the optimal clustering also
splits them then we are going to there
there is no aster extra cost
so suppose the optimal classroom
actually put them together
okay so i'm going to show you that the
optimal clustering has to pay a lot of
cost
so why because to consider a vertex that
is not inside uh
this is the same cluster that has a
positive edge uh connecting to this
uh to this right hand side right vertex
and then we are going to pay for this
positive match
and on the other hand consider a vertex
uh light blue vertically inside this
cluster so it is because it has a
positive edge to this uh
vertex but it has a negative edge
towards this right hand side
uh
red vertex so we're going to pay for the
next match
so
in this way
even though if the optimal classroom put
these two watches together the optimal
classroom is going to pay a lot of cost
and our algorithm should be competitive
against it okay
so that in this way they show that
they can achieve a constant
approximation
so now let's step back a little bit
so if you look at this classroom result
we will find that the algorithm put
these densely connected components
together okay they've densely connected
versus together and standalone vertices
uh apart okay in other was their
algorithm implicitly divide the graph
into two type of vertices the first ones
are densely kinetic components the
second type of vertices with sparse edge
connections and they implemented this
with six passes
so now our observation is that is this
kind of decomposition first of its kind
so the answer is no
there is this is this kind of powerful
tools called grafting sparse density
composition from the graph stream
literature the line of work actually
initiated from the
graph theory contacts and more recently
the distributing streaming graph
coloring
okay so now let me tell you a little bit
about what is sparse density composition
and why it helps correction classroom
so
a sparse test deposition roughly
speaking
categorize the vertices into two types
the first one is almost clicks which are
the vertices that are densely connected
with each other and their degrees are
around the maximum degree delta
and for the vertices that cannot join
any uh almost click we call them sparse
vertices
so a natural idea here is to decompose
the graph on the positive sub graph g
plus and then do the correlation
classroom based on the results
so
why this is good so let's look at it
from this example so in this example the
maximum degree is four okay and it says
like uh this is almost this is the four
clicks it's the four click and this is
almost four click okay so
based on the rule for sparseness this
decomposition we will put the
red vertices into almost clicks and
light blues vertices into sparse
vertices
so now what we can do we can put each
almost click as a cluster and each
sparse vertex has a single plaster okay
so why this is good so remember this is
a positive graph so for each almost
click there are very small number of
non-edges inside each almost click and
there are very small number of edges
outside so the cost is small for the low
degree spot vertex there's there are not
many uh edges on it positive edges on it
so the cost is small if we put it a
single turn and the interesting case is
this kind of light blue high degree
response vertices so it has many
positive um
edges but it has also has many known
edges which translates to negative edges
in a complete graph so whatever we do
even the optimal cluster has to pay a
lot of cost for it so if we put into
singapore it
won't be too bad for the correlation
classroom cost
okay so this is actually the main
takeaway of this talk so how
how sparse does decomposition helps
correlation classroom
but this is not the end of the story
now there are some major problems for
canonical graph sparse density
composition and one of the problem is
it only works with the maximum degree
delta but this is bad for correlation
classroom so why think about
this graph which has two big clicks and
one small clip
and now because uh canonical sparse
density composition works with the
maximum degree of delta so it will put
these
big clicks as almost clicks but every
vertex inside the small click at the
sparse vertex
and now if you do the same thing we put
almost clicks in a cluster and each
sponsor has a single tail so suppose
this small piece is of size root and
we're going to induce a cost of n okay
but it's optimal cost zero this is bad
so
one candidate to run the issue is the
loo called uh sponsors decomposition by
alan assani
so a local
sparsten's decomposition means that the
almost least is now dependent on look on
maximum degree for example they're just
we click here almost fine click here and
both of them will be uh identified as
almost clicks based on their local
maximum degree okay
so however
that version doesn't work for our
purpose either so there are some
problems with their uh guarantees for
the neighborhood of sports vertices and
more importantly their work emphasizes
on the existence of such decomposition
and it is not clear if we can do it
efficiently
okay so
to
get a sparse
density composition for correlation
constraint so we actually uh propose a
new type of sparseness composition
so the guiding principle here is that
for each almost click okay we we have
this loop almost clicks so for each
vertex v almost click k it has very
small number of known edges inside k and
the very small edges outside k and
inside is around the degree of b for
each vertex inside
to put it more concretely
so on the in this picture if v is inside
ki
and let's dot ki by the max degree in ki
okay for each vertex v it has at most
absolute key noun neighbors inside ki
and at most absolute k neighbors outside
ki and the size of ki is around delt ki
okay this is uh our new definition for
arms clicks
and we add in correspondence we also
have this new notion for local sports
vertices and vertically set to disperse
it has a if it has a subset of neighbors
as v such that one this subset has to be
large it has to be a constant fraction
of these neighborhoods and second for
each vertex units v the difference of
the neighborhoods between u and v is
large and different neighborhood
is defined and the vertical vertices
that are in the neighborhood of u but
not in the neighborhood v plus the
neighborhood of vertices v but not in
linear product of u
okay
so to put in the picture
if v the sparse vertex then it has a
large uh fraction of its neighbors as we
such that for each vertex you inside and
the the the
neighborhood between you and india is
different so
the difference between neighborhood is
large
okay
so now why this this new deposition is
good for correction clustering so well
i'm going to show you the algorithm for
it so now after doing the correlation
sorry after do the sparseness
decomposition we can do the old scheme
i've already shown you so we can put
each almost click into a cluster and for
each sparse vertex to create a singlet
okay so
in a flowchart algorithm will just be as
the following
so
the first thing i want to show is this
is good for college classroom
so note that there are three type of
calls you used by cloud our classroom
scheme the positive edges on the sparse
vertices the positive edges between
different almost clicks and the negative
adjacent inside each almost click
so now in the same spirit of the cool
added at all paper so we can actually
show that responsibilities incurs at the
most constant to the optimal times of
optimal classroom cost and similarly the
positive edges between different almost
clicks incurs and moves a constant times
optimal cost
on the other hand the negative edges
means that each almost clicking occurs
at the most optimal cost so in summary
gets out of an
approximation okay
now let me tell you a little bit about
why this is efficient now
so
notice that
conditioning we have the decomposition
we have the decomposition now we can do
this
we can assign clusters in order of
enzyme and memory we can just go over
the vertices look at its labels for in
this person's composition and then
assign the corresponding classrooms okay
so we can write order of end time and
space here
and now
how much time and space we need to find
the sparse density composition so the
good news is that by our definition we
can actually efficiently fund this uh
sparseness decomposition in some linear
timeline space
so in our paper we show that
if we are given the formal information
one is the degree of vertices two is the
a uh
random order of log login neighbors for
each vertex and the third information in
the neighborhood the whole neighborhood
information for a subset of vertices and
these subsets of vertices are somehow
with probability
around order of log n over degree of v
okay for for each v
and then if we give the three type of
the information then we can compute a
sparse density composition in order of n
log square and time
okay
so
now we can write a order of n log square
and time and order of n log and space
for for funds to compute this sparse
decomposition
[Music]
and now the only thing left is to obtain
the required samples for this
decomposition
and then we show that given the
adjustments for the positive sub graphs
this can be done in order for n log and
time and with the single parts over the
stream this can be done with other
unlocked edge memory okay so we can
write all together n here
and because some of these results
uh as the flow chart showed has shown us
so for the with the identities of
positives of graph we can obtain the
required samples uh in order of
unlocking time and then in a single part
of the stream we can do this in order of
unlocking memory
spend order of unlocked square and time
to recover the decomposition and order
of in time and memory for the classroom
scheme
okay good
so let me conclude by adding some
remarks
the first remark is the right model for
sublinear time algorithm so we know that
under the standard urgency list model
there's no uh finite finite
multiplication approximation and under
the g plus model we have a constant
approximation so it's g plus right model
so more or less
we
we can say this is yes because we also
give a lower bound for if if we are
given the negatives of graph g minus
instead
still with small of n square queries we
cannot achieve any finite multiplicative
approximation okay so the g plus the
most natural one for us to work on
and the other comments about our
streaming algorithm so we introduce our
streaming algorithm under the insertion
on a graph stream so we note that it can
be adapted to a dynamic graph stream
algorithm that can handle both insertion
and deletion with polylogin space
overhead and the reason is quite natural
is because our sparse skin's
decomposition only requires some holes
and if you're familiar with the
literature this can definitely be done
by this celebration of zero sum
so in summary we started some linear
time and space um algorithm for
correlation clustering in this paper
okay we propose the first linear time
algorithm to find the constant
approximation for correlation
transferring with order of and log
square and time giving the identities
for the positives of graph g plus
furthermore we
we design the first linear speed single
path streaming algorithm that find the
constant approximation for correlation
transferring with order from logan space
and we note that both of our algorithms
are randomized
so there are some open problems so one
is right now our constant is quite large
it turns to the fifth to ten to the
sixth so can we get a small constant for
that
and we believe that our algorithm works
much better
than the worst case uh approximation
factor on real-world graphs to leave the
empirical study as a future direction
and also another interesting problem is
to test the values for correlation
transferring in particular if you are
only allowed for login space now we are
not asked to output the class ring but
only output
the value of the clustering what can we
do for this
okay so that's it and there are some
references and thank